[Music]
what's up wisecrack jared again today
we're diving into the film series that's
equal parts heart and fart
dreamworks enduring fairy tale send up
shrek the shrek franchise is well known
for its signature brand of humor which
parodies fairy tales by juxtaposing
classic tropes of the genre with modern
day language attitudes and pop culture
references when the films are working
and they don't always they make us laugh
by showing us what happens when the way
we think the world ought to be crashes
up against the way that it actually is
at their best the films are a radical
celebration of diversity love and the
chaotic messiness of real life
overthrowing pretension rigidity and
prejudice at their worst well
but we'll get to that later welcome to
this wisecrack edition on the shrek
movies deep or dumb as always spoilers
ahead for an 18 year old franchise about
a scottish ogre and an annoying talking
donkey i'm making waffles alright guys
first a quick recap of the series to
date we meet shrek an ornery bachelor of
an ogre enjoying his life of solitude
and smash mouth shrek's idyllic
existence is turned upside down when one
lord farquaad transforms his beloved
swamp into a forced resettlement camp
for fairy tale creatures we were forced
to come here by who lord farquaad
he huffed and deported only
signed an eviction notice to get his
land back shrek agrees to go on a quest
he and chatterbox sidekick donkey will
rescue princess fiona from a dragon's
lair so that farquaad can marry her and
become a legitimate king what i mean is
uh you're not a king yet
but but you can become one all you have
to do is marry a princess on the way
back to duloc shrek and fiona
inadvertently fall in love and are
eventually married the rest of the films
in the series follow shrek and fiona
through several stereotypical hallmarks
of newlywed life meeting the parents in
shrek 2 preparing for parenthood in
shrek iii and adjusting to a more
settled lifestyle in shrek forever after
in the first film main antagonist lord
farquaad is obsessed with the pursuit of
perfection i'm not the monster here you
are you and the rest of that fairy tale
trash poisoning my perfect world but
what is perfection according to farquaad
it is a clean well-ordered kingdom
populated by citizens mechanically going
about the roles he has assigned to them
[Music]
even his desire to marry fiona is driven
by compulsive completionism more than
any real political need as lord of duloc
it is clear that he already wields
absolute power over his subjects to the
point of establishing a cult of
personality around his image but to be
de facto ruler is not enough for
farquaad he insists upon ruling as he
puts it the most perfect kingdom of them
all his desire to marry fiona comes not
from love but from a need to satisfy the
magic mirror's definition of kingship
will you be the perfect bride for the
perfect groom
farquaad and duloc are rigid and
inflexible insisting on arbitrary rules
and ideals rather than adapting to the
situation at hand many of the film's
best jokes work by drawing attention to
the vast gulf between their delusions
and their reality shrek thus serves as a
neat illustration of a theory of humor
developed by henri bergson in his 1900
essay collection laughter bergson argues
that the laughable element consists of a
certain mechanical inelasticity just
where one would expect to find the wide
awake adaptability and the living
pliableness of a human being in other
words continuing to move as a result of
momentum or continuing to act out a
preconceived notion of how the world
works this covers everything from
slipping on a surprise banana peel to
failing to adapt to changing social
circumstances am i so out of touch
no it's the children who are wrong enter
shrek shrek is everything farquaad is
not filthy smelly and pragmatic rather
than idealistic these traits make him
the ideal comic foil to a man with his
head firmly up his own ass and to the
society he has created shrek is the ugly
green reality check duloc desperately
needs whenever he encounters an
unnecessarily complex system or
highfalutin attitude his blunt approach
to life brings it crashing down where
there is a stifling order he deflates it
with humor or creative disorder i'm an
agent of chaos to kick the movie off
shrek literally wipes his ass with a
book of fairy tales
later he blatantly ignores social norms
which the human citizens of duloc follow
even when they believe their lives are
in immediate danger his no-nonsense
approach to fiona's rescue highlights
the obvious flaws in the princesses and
by proxy the audience's understanding of
heroism you're meant to charge in sword
drawn better fight
that's what all the other knights did
yeah right before they burst on the
flame even his speech patterns undercut
the pompous and fake medieval dialogue
used by characters caught up in their
own delusional stories wait mr knight
this be at our first meeting should it
not be a wonderful
romantic moment yeah
sorry lady
just by being himself shrek points out
the absurdities of people like farquaad
and places like dulon he simplifies and
loosens up things that have gotten over
complicated and inflexible at the same
time he complicates ideas the rest of
the world takes for granted most
importantly in standing up for himself
and ogres in general he calls into
question the idea that there can be a
simple binary division between good and
bad beauty and ugliness perfection and
imperfection he explains this to donkey
in one of the film's most iconic scenes
onions have layers ogres have layers
onions have layers
you get it we both have layers and later
man ain't none but a bunch of little
dots
you know donkey sometimes things are
more than they appear and in spite of
shrek sarcasm and for all the film's
reputation as a smart alecky postmodern
irony fest the film revolves around a
remarkably hopeful and earnest central
idea that real life in all its stench
and ugliness is way more fun and full of
love than the fantasies we dream up for
ourselves and that enjoying its
imperfections is the key to fulfillment
in the film's final moments the reality
of the friendship and love between shrek
and his band of misfits overcomes the
fantasy of a tyrant and turns him into
dragon chow i will have order i will
have perfection
ultimately these unorthodox but real
relationships break shrek out of his own
self-involved fantasy of contented
solitude they judge me before they even
know me
that's why i'm better off alone shrek
takes a decisive step towards happiness
ugly ever after in the movies language
when he finally accepts his developing
friendship with donkey and his feelings
for fiona so the first shrek movie deep
and score for jeffrey katzenberg's
upstart dreamworks studio sticking it to
the disney machine sorry michael eisner
it's okay
it's okay shrek 2 builds on the
foundation shrek lays down like the
first film the sequel gets a lot of its
laughs by dragging pompous figures like
prince charming through the mess of the
physical world he will rue the very day
he stole my kingdom from me
also like shrek shrek 2 takes a dim view
of government and the politicians who
run it while from the outside he appears
to be a decent enough king fiona's
father harold is ultimately revealed to
be in debt to and under the control of
the fairy godmother in other words he's
in the pocket of big business indeed by
turning the fairy godmother into a
literal manufacturer of happy endings
shrek 2 raises interesting questions
about one of the first film's guiding
ideas specifically in a world where the
strongest of human emotions are sold by
the gallon what is this true love that
the characters have been talking about
all this time is it even real you can't
force someone to fall in love
i beg to differ i do it all the time to
break it down even further the fairy
godmother maker of happy endings and
fake emotions isn't queen [ __ ] of just
any old kingdom she secretly wields
power over a town that is explicitly
designed to lampoon that place that
brews up a piping hot majority of our
own cultural bs beverly hills and nearby
hollywood from the letters on a hill
mimicking the iconic hollywood sign to
the store fronts and movie posters to
the red carpet that greets shrek and
fiona as they step out of their
horse-drawn limousine far far away is
full of visual cues linking it to a town
with a worldwide reputation for
superficiality run by an industry whose
main output is fictional stories meant
to stir up emotion by setting its story
in such a place the film draws attention
to the roles played by major hollywood
studios and the system in which they
operate in creating the out of touch
fantasies about love heroism and
perfection that inspired the series in
the first place adorno eat your heart
out ultimately the film answers its
questions about true love in much the
same way shrek did while raising the
stakes like a good sequel should
let's take a look like farquaad before
him harold is possessed by the need to
project an image of perfection to the
point where he sold away his daughter's
future to transform himself from a frog
into a human unlike farquaad harold
eventually redeems himself by saving
fiona from the fairy godmother's love
potion accepting his unusual son-in-law
for who he is and finally dropping his
human disguise you're more that man
today than you ever were
warts and all
then as the clock strikes midnight fiona
deliberately waits for the beauty potion
to wear off so she and shrek can revert
back to their usual selves i want what
any princess wants
to live happily ever after
with the ogre i married both of these
demonstrations of love for others
involve acceptance of imperfection but
with a twist unlike in the first movie
both harold and fiona are given
opportunities represented by the potions
to live out the rest of their lives
according to the societally sanctioned
model of happiness harold can maintain
his kingly appearance by roofing his
daughter and fiona can have a body that
fits normative standards of hotness by
sealing the beauty potion with a kiss
imbued with this new power of choice
both father and daughter still reject
superficial perfection in favor of
imperfect but true love so shrek 2 gets
a deep and this unfortunately is where
things take a turn for the stupid
clocking in at a long 92 minutes shrek
iii represents a bizarre departure from
everything the series had stood for thus
far with harold dead and fiona pregnant
shrek is terrified by the looming
responsibilities of kingship and
fatherhood
[Music]
hoping to get at least one thing off his
plate shrek tracks down arthur pendragon
harold's nephew and the only other
viable heir to the throne in his absence
prince charming raises an army of
jealous villains to invade far far away
and secure their own happily ever afters
the final showdown sees young arthur
step into his role as king by convincing
the villains that only they have the
power to make themselves happy while the
film does have a few great stand-alone
jokes well well it isn't peter pan his
name's not peter shut it wendy
it's missing the core of what made the
first two movies in the series so
powerful listen to arthur's big speech
to the villains you're telling me you
just want to be villains your whole
lives didn't you ever wish you could be
something else if there's something you
really want or someone you really want
to be
then the only person standing in your
way
is you
me coming from this series this is
really really dumb putting aside for a
moment that arthur seems to have lifted
his dialogue straight from a youtube
workout motivation video what's so off
about this moment is that it completely
undercuts what the series has done so
far shrek and shrek 2 point out the
inherent problems in black and white
thinking dividing people into camps of
good and bad heroes and villains is both
unrealistic and harmful the films
culminate in main characters accepting
and even celebrating the inevitably
flawed reality they inhabit shrek the
turd you heard me uncritically promotes
the idea of villainy as an objective
state of being one that villains can
escape only by aligning their behavior
with what is socially acceptable it
completely scans the complex discussion
around acceptance that carries the first
two films and opts instead for warmed
over cliches from a self-help seminar oh
and you get the privilege of watching a
group of teenage girls hit on a
middle-aged man
this is like totally embarrassing but my
friend tiffany thinks that affects her
so soothly and she thought perchance
that would want to ask her to the
homecoming dance or something excuse me
it's like whatever she's just totally
into college guys and mythical creatures
and stuff this movie is dumb
shrek forever after doesn't fare much
better like shrek iii it does have some
standout moments also like shrek iii it
completely abandons the take on
happiness and imperfection that made the
first two entries in the series so
interesting the film is a shrek style
spin on the it's a wonderful life
formula you'll remember from the
original jimmy stewart production that
muppet christmas movie where kermit gets
traumatized by a restaurant serving frog
legs and many other iterations feeling
trapped by the daily grind of
responsible parenthood shrek makes an
impulsive deal with rumpelstiltskin and
winds up stuck in a world in which he
was never born and therefore never
married fiona met his friends or had his
children after learning the value of
what he lost shrek is able to nullify
his contract with rumple by sucking face
with underground ogre resistance leader
fiona and return to his family all of
which sounds fine and dandy until you
look at the fine print it's fine print
is crafted listen to the last thing
fiona says to shrek before he makes his
deal you have three
beautiful children
a wife who loves you
friends who adore you
you have everything now membership in a
nuclear family and the support of a good
network may be good things to have but
the fiona who gorged on weed rat
rotisserie style challenged her husband
to a fart contest in a mud bath and
chose to remain an ogre rather than
change the person she loved would not
say that these conventional markers of
success and happiness are everything the
film puts shrek in a position similar to
that of the villains at the end of shrek
iii above and beyond attending to the
responsibilities of fatherhood he is
being asked to abandon key parts of an
identity that brings him joy and a sense
of purpose although people inevitably
and rightfully sacrifice a lot for their
families it's romanticized in a way
reminiscent of duloc he's expected to
insert himself into an accepted cultural
narrative of what a perfect life is in
other words to completely buy into the
story manufactured in far far away a
fairy tale that the series spent two
remarkable movies trying to dismantle
shrek forever after is dumb and no
amount of bestiary gingy can make it
deep so it looks like we have a tie
while there's no getting around the fact
that the series lost a lot of depth as
time went on the later films still offer
their fair share of weird clever jokes
not all of them grounded in pop culture
references it's time to pay the piper
griselda seriously it's time to pay the
piper now go get my checkbook and the
film's best work is often more complex
than the series as a whole gets credit
for well maybe you're right princess so
what do you think wisecrack are these
films deeper or dumber than we've
determined here today did you spot
something that we missed is shrek in the
swamp karaoke dance party canon and
could lord farquaad still be alive
inside dragon's cavernous stomach let us
know your thoughts in the comments below
peace
[Music]
you